The joe rogan experience.
I can do a lot in 1975
with $1,000 with two kids.
My grandmother was
obsessed with the numbers.
She was obsessed and she
would always have like, um,
numbered her head that she thought it was
going to be and it was like one off or
something like that. It was like
these stories she would tell you.
What would you say? What
can I say? I was like five.
I just remember it very distinctly.
My grandmother went to jail for running
numbers in New Jersey. She wouldn't,
she wouldn't rat him out. So they put
her in jail. So she made sweaters,
gave sweaters to the guards.
Mrs D, She's the nicest lady.
Do you feel that your grandmother
had done time? What did you think?
We didn't find out until I was probably
like, I wonder when I found out,
I think maybe I found out my
teenage years and I was like, why?
What the fuck people would go
to see her? Like, where's a,
I don't want to say my grandma's name
and a respect, but people would say,
you know, where is she? Oh, she went
to visit her, her cousin her is,
she wants to see her aunt and she's,
you know,
she's in the pokey for like six months.
I forget how much time it was,
but every time we'd go over there
there's like some new excuse,
see it in New Jersey, then punch it in New
Jersey. They put you in jail for again.
I get to New York City, they don't,
they give you a ticket, you know,
they would give you like a ticket
in the shit and those days,
I don't know what it's like now.
This fucking,
they'll throw you in jail for weed down
in New York City. I don't fucking know.
My grandmother was one of the few people
I've ever known where I legitimately
thought they had intuition.
She has weird intuition.
She would do things.
It's real weird.
Like when my mother was a a kid,
it was a rainstorm.
I was like real bad rainstorm and for
whatever reason my grandmother decided to
wake my mother up, take her out of
her bed and bring her downstairs.
Some crazy hunch.
She had the ceilings,
claps like right above the bed where
my mom was sleeping. So like pieces of,
you know, it wasn't a lot, it was just
chunks of plaster, but like, you know,
three or four pretty significant pieces
of plaster fell off of the ceiling.
It was rain came through
with the whole deal.
I'll just sealing gave out and somehow
or another she had this idea in her head
and it could be because she knew that
the ceiling was fucked up and she knew it
was raining hard.
It was probably going to give in any way
or she might've had an intuition and my
fault, everyone was always
convinced it was intuition.
Everyone's always convinced like
she's like a little bit psychic.
It was always weird. It was always
weird around there. Well because shaky,
the shame about her monkey. No, she
had a month and New Jersey. Yes,
in north New Jersey. She had a monkey
named Chichi and cheats you a bite.
Everybody.
But my grandma,
my grandfather made and keep the monkey
in the attic. Y'All. My grandma was crazy
z.
She had a monkey would open up
packages a gum and chew gum.
How or where the fuck she got it
from? Bottom up. I'm telling you,
my grandma was crazy. Italian people had
butches days and they get you anything.
She Kelly Gaina pigeon. She
kept a monkey in the house, man.
Do you understand how crazy then you
remember the monkey? Yes. Cheat Sheet.
The monkeys came as cheesy bites. You
know he never bit me. He bit my sister.
He bit my sister. Yeah. Cheat. You would
fuck you up. I think he bit my sister.
I think he tried to bite my sister.
I think it was one of those things
they might have bit my cousin
in our family got pit.
That's dumb.
I couldn't see the side.
No Italian side. Yeah.
Then she was crazy and once you give,
no disrespect,
but once you get those little ticks,
that option that they do have intuition,
you're fucking done. They start
giving you the fish eyes. Dude,
don't do shit. You got listened to.
Her cooking was from another planet.
It's from another planet.
It was like pure immigrant cooking.
Like the pasta that loves design.
Yeah. You just sit there and go,
Holy Shit.
Just perfect.
Just knew exactly what to post to
be in there. She baked her own,
like she would make her own macaroni,
should make our own Ravioli.
She would stuff her own Ravioli.
She'd be out there role in and
flatten out flour and shit,
throwing the flower on top of it,
flatten it out. She was a wizard though.
He should get a monkey,
call it cheat TD.
Gotta respect a little
monkey and keep her head dog.
Either respectful or grandma.
My grandma was a special lady.
She was powerful once you give those.
So when I was a kid, man, I went to
my buddy's judo school. I didn't join.
I just went down there to see what it was
like. And it was hidden in union city.
It was on seventh street,
but I knew that my stepdad played
cards on ninth street on Wednesdays.
Wow. Okay. I knew my stepdad played
cards down and they played baccarat.
Okay.
And they'd gamble in this little club
and I had to be maybe 10 but because I
grew up, how I grew up with the numbers,
I always had my eyes out as a kid.
When I went to judo that met at the end,
I got on the bus to go back and
I noticed unmarked police cars
and I went home that night and look bro,
you know,
made dog get Christie love used to be a
show on ABC about a black chick that new
martial arts and tried to
capitalize on it with a sister.
And she was good looking with an Afro
when she was a cop that she'd come in and
do karate moves on Wednesday nights at
nine or 10 o'clock and you caught me at
home watching get Christie,
I'll never forget that my stepdad was
leaving that night and for some reason I
know you're going to play back home
after that. And he looked at me,
he was getting dressed or suit on. Yeah,
like the Billy bad Sudan and the shit.
You're going to play cards or five men.
Why are you getting dressed to the nines?
And I said to him, I said, hey man,
today I went down and let it
go to Martins judo school.
And I saw a bunch of them marked
cards down there. If I was you,
I wouldn't go out to that.
And He fucking just looked at me.
He said, I love you. And he walked down
the stairs. He got in the car, started it,
opened the garage bro.
And 10 minutes later I heard the car
turned off in the garage close and he came
up and he goes,
I think you're right.
And he made Sundays for me and him and
next morning and that card place I got
raided. So now they would listen to me. I,
I had these fucking
morons out that my spouse.
But you want me to tell you what
else did Joe Rogan like? This is me.
And like me and my stepdad
had this weird relationship.
I got to an age where I wanted my
mother from myself. You know what?
The feeling is dry when
we've all gone through it.
When you lose a dad and your mom remarries
that comes up a day that he's not
going to tell you what's going on anymore.
And you know what?
I just want you to know that I'm the
motherfucker that runs this joint.
You might be sleeping with my mum,
but I run this motherfucker.
So once I gave him that advice,
like it really for a while,
then him and I would go in a float.
I kept stealing his coins from the center.
He had this sand Laszlo thing
and that was everything to him.
So he had this big bottle of like scotch
that was empty and he would put silver
dollars in there and I would steal them.
And from time to time he would come home
and go, that bottle's looking light,
somebody stealing,
destroying his mind for years,
because he was a very particular man.
So he had different bundles of my life.
I'll tell you something,
I respect them today because I saw him
get out of the joint and I show what he
did with bookmaking and how he
became partners on a butcher shop.
I started businesses, he started
different businesses. So, uh,
after I saved this that night with the
backer rock, he would listen to me.
And then one day I went and I signed up
for bitty basketball and union city and
they used to give, you know,
like now if you sign your kid up,
you've got to pay any dollars.
In those days you just show up at an
address and they gave you a tee shirt,
they put you on the team and they
gave me a number. They said like,
you didn't say department of recreation
and was a purple shirt. My number was 57.
I walked in the house and he goes,
what do you got there? And I go, Oh,
I joined the basketball thing and he
goes, what number is? And he goes,
57 Cubans again, a very
superstitious 50, 70 goes,
put a number on that. And he
picked up the phone. I go five.
He called some guy and he goes, give
me five 57 for $10. Guess what happens?
Your rug, what happened?
The number came up. No,
I really had them under my spell right.
The fuck out.
Said I had this motherfucker at the
age of 12, so he would listen to me.
How old was the guy?
My stepfather,
Juan at the time was 47.
Did Not drink. Get imagine,
did not drink, did not do
drugs. Carry the straight razor.
Joe Rogan a straight razor to cut
people. Yeah. And he used to cut,
you use the web carpenter
pants with the stray raise.
At this point the guy had money,
he would have a gold chain.
He wear a Chinese tee shirt, which a
lot of people do not know what it is.
That's what real pimps where there's
silk and may shirts from China that you
went and they have three little buttons.
Well,
when you were real motherfucking Spec,
you cut those buttons and you get your
initials and you put them in gold with
diamonds in it. That's how
speaks ran in those days. Well,
and uh, once I had them there, Joe
Rogan, I had him, he trusted me.
He trusted my eyes.
So one night we're in union city and I
fucking went somewhere on the walk back,
there's a place called pastoral music and
there was next to the new moon Chinese
restaurant and I saw a bunch of unmarked
cars and I'll never forget that.
I went back to the bar and then he'd
go out and I told him, I said, dog.
I saw three on my, like I
had him and I go, that's him.
I seen three on my cars up the corner.
He was very always scared of the
phone even though he was a bookmaker,
he never used the phone.
Joe Rogan never used the phone and he
would never have a conversation close to a
phone. This is because he always
felt he didn't let him like phones.
He did everything like a pigeon.
His,
he would write the numbers and the
little piece of paper real small and fold
them up and put him in his hat.
And if he ever saw cops,
he would just eat a piece of fucking
paper. He didn't give a fuck.
He always had the piece
of paper somewhere close.
Sometimes you will put it in this ring.
This motherfucker was a savage. Oh my God.
So that might, the cops were
going to jump on us on the bar,
but it was for a drug thing. It wasn't
for him. But when I went back, I told him,
listen,
the cops are up to corner and me and him,
he grabbed me by the hand and him and
I walked from 29th in Bergen Line,
the 58th and Bergen line down the Hudson
telling different bar owners that there
was going to be a raid. Like that's
how are untrustworthy. He was a phones.
By the time we got back to the bar,
we got raided and there was a dude in,
his name was Monina.
Right. Monina is those, uh,
those crazy Cubans that I've acquired.
Monina means good man.
Like y'all my bra. Yeah, the albacore
while they're the ones that only pussy.
And then he puts a,
and they fucking,
you can't fuck around with animals because
they're saying Lazarus and all that
show. They have a very specific religion.
Yeah. They have their ma. It's a manhood.
They were longshoremen and Cuba.
And they maintain order,
so we have a fuck up. They'd come
over and fuck you up. There was,
but he had a wig.
I'll never forget this.
The Guy Monina had a wig and the cops were
there and they threw him and I'm like,
12 dog.
I'm up against the wall,
the search and made through
the search and my step dad,
they got my mom and they went to Monina
and they searched him and the cop looked
at his work and he goes,
check the wig.
And they pulled the wig off and he had
a little aluminum foil, weed, cocaine.
Oh my God. Oh my God. That's hilarious.
That whole bookmaking numbers world
is fucking nuts that I grew up in.
I love it still.
Okay.